and so today I kind of just want to
cover the fundamentals of Pi torch
um really just kind of see what are the
similarities between pi torch and numpy
and python which you guys are used to at
this point
and see how we can build up a lot of the
building blocks that we'll need in order
to Define more complex models so
specifically we're going to talk today
about tensors what are tensor objects
how do we manipulate them
uh what is auto grad how pytorch helps
us compute different gradients
and finally how we actually do
optimization and how we write the
training Loop for our neural networks
and if we have time at the end then
we'll try and go through a bit of a demo
to kind of put everything together and
see how everything comes together when
you want to solve an actual NLP task
all right so let's get started
so if you go to the course website
there's a notebook
and you can just make a copy of this
collab notebook and then just run the
cells as we go
and so to start today we're talking
about Pi torch like I said it's a deep
learning framework that really does two
main things one is it makes it very easy
to author and manipulate tensors and
make use of your GPU so that you can
actually leverage a lot of that
capability and two is it makes the
process of authoring neural networks
much simpler you can now use different
building blocks like linear layers and
different loss functions and compose
them in different ways in order to
author the types of models that you need
for your specific use cases
and so pytorch is one of the two main
Frameworks along with tensorflow in this
class we'll focus on Pi torch but
they're quite similar and so we'll start
by importing torch and we'll import the
neural network module which is torch.nn
and for this first part of the tutorial
I want to talk a bit about tensors one
thing that you guys are all familiar
with now is numpy arrays and so pretty
much you can think about tensors as
the equivalent in pi torch to numpy
arrays they're essentially
multi-dimensional arrays that you can
manipulate in different ways and you'll
essentially use them to represent your
data to be able to actually manipulate
it and perform all the different Matrix
operations that underlie your neural
network
and so in this case for example if we're
thinking of an image one way you can
think about it in terms of a tensor is
it's a 256 by 256 tensor where it's has
a width of 256 pixels and a height of
256 pixels and for instance if we have a
batch of images and those images contain
three channels like red green and blue
then we might have a four-dimensional
tensor which is the batch size by the
number of channels by the width and the
height and so everything we're going to
see today is all going to be represented
as tensors which you can just think of
as multi-dimensional arrays
and so to kind of get some intuition
about this we're going to spend a little
bit of time going through essentially
lists of lists and how we can convert
them into tensors and how we can
manipulate them with different
operations
so to start off with we just have
a simple list of lists that you're all
familiar with in this case it's a two by
three list
and now we want to create a tensor and
so here the way we'll create this tensor
is by doing torch.tensor and then
essentially writing the same
syntax that we had before just write out
the list of lists that represents that
particular tensor
and so in this case we get back a tensor
object which is the same shape and
contains the same data
and so now the second thing with the
tensor is that it contains a data type
so there's different data types for
instance there are different varying
level of precision floating Point
numbers that you can use you can have
integers you can have different data
types that actually populate your tensor
and so by default I believe this will be
float32 but you can explicitly specify
which data type your tensor is by
passing in the d-type argument
and so we see here now even though we
you know wrote in a bunch of integers
they have a decimal point which
indicates that they're floating Point
numbers
and so same thing here we could
create another tensor in this case with
data type float32
and
in this third example you see that we
create another tensor we don't actually
specify the data type but pytorch
essentially implicitly takes the data
type to be floating points since we
actually passed in a floating Point
number into this tensor
so
pretty much at a high level tensors are
like multi-dimensional arrays we can
specify the data type for them we can
populate them just like numpy rays
okay so now great we know how to create
tensors we know that ultimately
everything that we work with all the
data we have is going to be expressed as
tensors
now the question is what are the
functions that we have to manipulate
them
and so we have some basic utilities that
can help us instantiate tensors easily
specifically torch.zeros and torch.1s
these are
two ways to create tensors of a
particular shape in this case tensors of
all zeros or tensors of all ones and
you'll see that this will be very
helpful
when you do your homeworks typically
you'll you'll want to just need to just
create a bunch of zero Matrix and it'll
be very easy to just specify the shape
here without having to write everything
out super explicitly and then you can
update that tensor as needed
another thing you can do is just like we
have ranges in Python so if you want to
Loop over a bunch of numbers you can
specify a range you can also use
torch dot a range to be able to actually
instantiate a tensor with a particular
range in this case we just looped over
the numbers one through ten you could
reshape this and make it one through
five and then six through ten that's
another way to be able to instantiate
tensors
and finally
something to note is that
when we apply particular operations such
as just simple python operations like
addition or multiplication by default
they're going to be element wise so
they'll apply to all the elements in our
tensor so in this case we took our
tensor I think this one was probably
from earlier above and we added two
everywhere here we've multiplied
everything by two
but pretty much the pi torch semantics
for broadcasting work pretty much the
same as the numpy semantics so if you
pretty much have different Matrix
operations where you need to batch
across a particular Dimension pytorch
will be smart about it and it will
actually make sure that you broadcast
over the appropriate Dimensions although
of course you have to make sure that the
shapes are compatible based on the
actual broadcasting rules so we'll get
to that in a little bit when we look at
reshaping and how the bra uh how
different you know operations have those
semantics in this case we have to define
the I guess I'm not personally aware of
how you would Define kind of a jagged
tensor that has unequal dimensions
um but typically we don't want to do
that because it makes our computation a
lot more complex and so in cases where
we have you know for instance we have
different sentences that we turn into
tokens
we might have different length sentences
in our training set we'll actually pad
all the dimensions to be the same
because ultimately we want to do
everything with Matrix operations and so
in order to do that we need to have a
matrix of a fixed shape
um but yeah that's that's a good point I
I'm not sure if there is a way to do
that but typically we just get around
this by padding
okay so now we know how to define
tensors
we can do some interesting things with
them so here we've created two tensors
one of them is a three by two tensor the
other one is a two by four tensor and I
think the answer is written up here but
what do we expect is the shape when we
multiply these two tensors
so we have a three by two tensor and a
two by four tensor
yeah three by four
and so
more generally
um we can use matte mole in order to do
matrix multiplication it also implements
batch to matrix multiplication and so I
won't go over the entire review of
broadcasting semantics but the main gist
is that
the dimensions of two tensors are
compatible if you can left pad the
tensors with ones so that the dimensions
that line up either a have the same
number in that Dimension or B one of
them is a dummy Dimension one of them
has a one
and in that case in those dummy
Dimensions Pi torch will actually make
sure to copy over the tensor as many
times as needed so that you can then
actually perform the operation and
that's useful when you want to do things
like batch dot products or bashed Matrix
multiplications
and I guess the final Point here is
there's also a shorthand notation that
you can use so instead of kind of having
to type out matte mole every time you
can just use the add operator similar to
numpy effectively that's kind of where
we get into how batching works so for
example if you had
um let's say two tensors that have
um
some batch Dimension and then one of
them is M by one and the other one is
one by n
and if you do a batched matrix multiply
to those two tensors now what you
effectively do is you preserve the batch
Dimension and then you're doing a matrix
multiplication between an M by one
tensor and a one by n so you get
something that's the batch Dimension by
m by n so effectively they're kind of
more I think the full semantics are
written out on the pytorch website for
how the matrix multiplication works but
you're right you don't just have these
cases where you have two two dimensional
tensors you can have arbitrary number of
dimensions and as long as the dimensions
match up based on those semantics I was
saying then you can multiply it
alternatively you can do what I do which
is just multiply it anyways and then if
it throws an error print out the shapes
and kind of work from there that tends
to be faster in my opinion a lot of ways
but yeah that's a good point
all right so yeah let's keep going
through some of the other different
functionalities here
so we can Define another tensor
um and kind of one of the key things
that we always want to look at is the
shape so in this case we just have a 1D
tensor of length three so the torch dot
size just gives us three in general this
is kind of one of the key debugging
steps and something that I'll try and
emphasize a lot throughout this session
which is printing the shapes of all of
your tensors is probably your best
resource when it comes to debugging it's
kind of one of the hardest things to
Intuit exactly what's going on once you
start stacking a lot of different
operations together so printing out the
shapes at each point and seeing do they
match what you expect is something
important and it's better to rely on
that than just on the error message that
pytorch gives you because under the hood
pytorch might Implement certain
optimizations and
actually reshape the underlying tensor
you have so you may not see the numbers
you expect so it's always great to print
out the shape
and
so yeah let's uh so again we can always
print out the shape
and we can have a more complex uh in
this case a three-dimensional tensor
which is three by two by four and we can
print out the shape and we can see all
the dimensions here
and so now you're like okay great we
have tensors we can look at their shapes
but what do we actually do with them and
so now let's get into kind of what are
the operations that we can apply to
these tensors
and so one of them is it's very easy to
reshape tensors
so in this case we're creating this 15
dimensional tensor that's the numbers 1
to 15 and now we're reshaping it so now
it's a five by three tensor here
and so you might wonder well like what's
what's the point of that and it's
because a lot of times when we are doing
machine learning we actually want to
learn in batches and so we might take
our data and we might reshape it so now
that instead of kind of being a long
flat and list of things we actually have
a set of batches or in in some cases we
have a set of batches of a set of
sentences or sequences of a particular
length and each of the elements in that
sequence has an embedding of a
particular dimension and So based on the
types of operations that you're trying
to do you'll sometimes need to reshape
those tensors and sometimes you'll want
to
particularly sometimes transpose
Dimensions if you want to for instance
reorganize your data so
that's another operation to keep in mind
I believe the differences view will
um
view will create a view of the
underlying tensor and so I think the
underlying tensor will still have the
same shape reshape will actually modify
the tensor
um
all right and then finally like I said
at the beginning
your intuition about pytorch tensors can
simply be their kind of a nice easy way
to work with numpy arrays but they have
all these great properties like now we
can essentially use them with gpus and
it's very optimized and we can also
compute gradients quickly and
to kind of just emphasize this point if
you have some numpy code and you have a
bunch of numpy arrays you can directly
convert them into Pi torch sensors by
simply catch casting them
and you can also take those tensors and
convert them back to numpy arrays
all right and so one of the things you
might be asking is why do we care about
tensors what makes them good
and one of the great things about them
is that they support vectorized
operations very easily essentially we
can parallelize a lot of different
computations and do them for instance
across a batch of data all at once and
one of those operations you might want
to do for instance is a sum so
you can take in this case a tensor which
is
shape five by seven
and
it looks like that's not working
you can take a tensor that's shaped five
by seven and now you can compute
different operations on it that
essentially collapse the dimensionality
so the first one is sum and so you can
take it and you can sum across both the
rows as well as the columns and so one
way I like to think about this to kind
of keep them straight is that the
dimension that you specify in the sum is
the dimension you're collapsing so in
this case if you take the data and sum
over Dimension zero because you know the
shape of the underlying tensor is five
by seven
you've collapsed the zeroth dimension so
you should be left with something that's
just shape seven
and if you see the actual tensor you got
75 80 85 90. you get this tensor which
is shape seven
alternatively you can think about
whether or not you're kind of summing
across the rows or something across the
columns
but it's not just some it applies to
other operations as well you can compute
standard deviations you can normalize
your data you can do other operations
which essentially batch across the
entire set of data
and not only do these apply over one
dimension but here you can see that if
you don't specify any dimensions then by
default the operation actually applies
to the entire tensor so here we end up
just taking the sum of the entire thing
so if you think about it the zeroth
dimension is the number of rows there
are five rows and there are seven
columns so if we sum out the rows then
we're actually summing across the
columns
and so now we only have seven values
but I like to think about more just in
terms of the dimensions to keep it
straight rather than rows or columns
because it can get confusing if you're
summing out Dimension zero then
effectively you've taken something which
has some shape that's Dimension Zero by
Dimension One to just whatever is the
dimension one shape
and then from there you can kind of
figure out okay which way did I actually
sum to check if you were right numpy
implements a lot of this vectorization
and I believe in the homework that
you have right now I think part of your
job is to vectorize a lot of these
things
so the big Advantage with pi torch is
that essentially it's optimized to be
able to take advantage of your GPU when
we actually start building out neural
networks that are bigger that involve
more computation we're going to be doing
a lot of these matrix multiplication
operations that it's going to be a lot
better for our processor if we can make
use of the GPU and so that's where
pytorch really comes in handy
in addition to also defining a lot of
those neural network modules as we'll
see later for you so that now you don't
need to worry about for instance
implementing a basic linear layer and
back propagation from scratch and also
your Optimizer all of those things will
be built in and you can just call the
respective apis to make use of them
whereas in Python and numpy you might
have to do a lot of that coding yourself
all right so
we'll keep going
so this is a quiz except I think it
tells you the answer so it's not much of
a quiz
but
pretty much you know what would you do
if now I told you instead of you know
summing over this tensor I want you to
compute the average
and so there's there's two different
ways you could compute the average you
could compute the average across the
rows or across the columns
and so essentially
now we kind of get back to this question
of well which dimension am I actually
going to reduce over and so here if we
want to preserve the rows then we need
to actually sum over the second
dimension
um
they're really the first uh zeroth and
first so the First Dimension is what we
have to sum over because we want to
preserve the zeroth dimension
and so that's why for row average you
see the dim equals one
and for column average same reasoning is
why you see the dim equals zero
and so if we run this code we'll see
kind of what are the shapes that we
expect if we're taking the average over
rows then an object that's two by three
should just become an object that's two
it's just a one-dimensional
almost a vector you can think of
and if we are averaging across the
columns there's three columns so now our
average should have three values and so
now we're left with a three a
one-dimensional tensor of length three
so yeah does that kind of make sense I
guess is this General intuition about
how we deal with shapes and how some of
these operations manipulate shapes
so now we'll get into indexing
this can get a little bit tricky
but
I think you'll find that the semantics
are very similar to numpy
so one of the things that you can do in
numpy is that you can take these numpy
arrays and you can slice across them in
many different ways you can create
copies of them
and you can index across particular
Dimensions to select out different
elements different rows or different
columns
and so in this case let's take this
example tensor which is
three by two by two
and
first thing you'll always want to do
when you have a new tensor print out its
shape understand what you're working
with
and so
I guess uh
I may have shown this already but what
will X bracket zero print out what
happens if we index into just the first
element
what's the shape of this
yeah two by two right because if you
think about it our tensor is really just
a list of three things each of those
things happens to also be a two by two
tensor so we get a two by two object in
this case the first thing one two three
four
and so just like numpy if you provide a
colon in a particular Dimension it means
essentially copy over that dimension
so if we do X bracket zero implicitly
we're essentially putting a colon for
all the other dimensions so it's
essentially saying grab the first thing
along the zeroth dimension and then grab
everything along the other two
dimensions
if we now
take uh just the zeroth along the
element along the First Dimension
um
what are we going to get well
ultimately we're going to get now if you
look uh the kind of First Dimension were
these three things the second dimension
is now each of these two rows within
those things so like one two and three
four five six and seven eight
9 10 and 11 12. so if we index into the
second dimension or the First Dimension
and get the zeroth element
then we're going to end up with one two
by six and nine ten
and
even if that's a little bit tricky you
can kind of go back to the trick I
mentioned before where we're slicing
across the First Dimension so if we look
at the shape of our tensor it's three by
two by two
if we collapse the First Dimension that
two in the middle we're left with
something that's three by two
so it might seem a little bit trivial
kind of going through this in a lot of
detail but I think it's important
because it can get tricky when your
tensor shapes get more complicated how
to actually reason about this
and so I won't go through every example
here since a lot of them kind of
reinforce the same thing but I'll just
highlight a few things just like numpy
you can choose to get a range of
elements
in this case
where we're taking this new tensor which
is
one two one through fifteen rearranged
that's a five by three tensor and if we
take the zero through third row
um exclusive we'll get the first three
rows
and we can do the same thing but now
with slicing across multiple dimensions
and I think the final point I want to
talk about here is list indexing
list indexing is also present in numpy
and it's a very clever shorthand for
being able to essentially select out
multiple elements at once
so in this case what you can do is
if you want to get the zeroth the second
and the fourth element
of our Matrix you can just instead of
indexing with a particular number or set
of numbers index with a list of indices
so in this case if we go up to our
tensor
if we take out the zeroth the second and
the fourth we should see those three
rows
and that's what we end up getting
yeah again these are kind of a lot of
examples to just reiterate the same
point which is that you can slice across
your data in multiple ways and at
different points you're going to need to
do that
so being familiar with the shapes that
you understand what's the underlying
output that you expect is important
in this case for instance we're slicing
across the first and the second
dimension and we're keeping the first uh
the zeroth and so
we're going to end up getting
essentially kind of the the top left
element of each of those three things in
our tensor if we scroll all the way
up here we'll get this one we'll get
this five and we'll get this nine
because we go across all of this the
Earth Dimension and then across the
first and the second we only take the
first
uh
the the zeroth element in both of those
positions and so that's why we get 1 5
9.
and also of course you can you know
apply all of the colons to get back the
original tensor
okay and then I think the last thing
when it comes to indexing is conversions
so typically when we're writing code
with neural networks ultimately we're
going to
you know process some data through a
network and we're going to get a loss
and that loss needs to be a scalar and
then we're going to compute gradients
with respect to that loss so one thing
to keep in mind is that sometimes you
might have an operation and it fails
because it was actually expecting a
scalar value rather than a tensor and so
you can extract out the scalar from this
one by one tensor by just calling dot
item
so in this case you know if you have a
tensor which is just literally one then
you can actually get the python scalar
that corresponds to it by calling dot
item
so now we can get into the more
interesting stuff
one of the really cool things with
pytorch is autograd
and what autograd is is high torch
essentially provides an automatic
differentiation package where when you
define your neural network you're
essentially defining many nodes that
compute some function
and in the forward past you're kind of
running your data through those nodes
but what pytorch is doing on the back
end is that each of those points it's
going to actually store the gradients
and accumulate them so that every time
you do your backwards pass
you apply the chain rule to be able to
calculate all these different gradients
and pytorch caches those gradients
and then you will have access to all of
those gradients to be able to actually
then run your favorite Optimizer and
optimize you know with SGD or with atom
or whichever Optimizer you choose
and so that's kind of one of the great
features you don't have to worry about
actually writing the code that computes
all these gradients and actually caches
all of them properly applies the chain
rule does all these steps you can have
shocked all of that away with just one
call to dot backward
and so in this case we'll run through a
little bit of an example where we'll see
the gradients getting computed
automatically
so
in this case we're going to initialize a
tensor
and requires grad is true by default it
just means that by default for a given
tensor
python
pytorch will store the gradient
associated with it and you might wonder
well you know why why uh why do we have
this you know when we always want to
store the gradient and the answer is at
train time you need the gradients in
order to actually train your network but
at inference time you'd actually want to
disable your gradients and you can
actually do that because it's a lot of
extra computation that's not needed
since you're not making any updates to
your Network anymore
and so let's create this right now
uh we don't have any gradients uh being
computed because we haven't actually
called backwards to actually compute
um
some quantity with respect to this
particular tensor we haven't actually
computed
um those gradients yet so right now the
dot grad feature which will actually
store the gradient associated with that
tensor is not
and so now let's just Define a really
simple function we have X we're going to
define the function y equals 3x squared
and so now we're going to call Y dot
backward
and so now what happens is when we
actually print out x dot grad what we
should expect to see is number 12. and
the reason is that
our function y is 3x squared if we
compute the gradient of that function
we're going to get 6x
and our actual value was 2. so the
actual gradient is going to be 12.
and we see that when we print out X talk
grad that's what we get
and now we'll just run it again let's
set Z equal to 3x squared we call Z dot
backwards and we print out X talk grad
again and now we see that
I may not run this in the right order
Okay so
here in the second one that I re-rad we
see that it says 24. and so you might be
wondering well I just did the same thing
twice shouldn't I see 12 again
and the answer is that by default
pytorch will accumulate the gradients so
it won't actually rewrite the gradient
each time you compute it it will sum it
and the reason is because when you
actually have back propagation for your
network you want to accumulate the
gradients you know across all of your
examples and then actually apply your
update you don't want to overwrite the
gradient but this also means that every
time you have a training iteration for
your network you need to zero out the
gradient because you don't want the
previous gradients from the last Epoch
where you iterated through all of your
training data to mess with the current
update that you're doing
so that's kind of one thing to note
which is that
that's essentially why we will see when
we actually write the training Loop you
have to run zero grad in order to zero
out the gradient
yes so I accidentally ran the cells in
the wrong order maybe to make it more
clear let me put this one first
so this is actually what it should look
like which is that we ran it once and I
ran this cell first and it has 12. and
then we ran it a second time and we get
24.
yes so if you have all of your tensors
defined
then when you actually called out
backwards if it's a function of multiple
variables it's going to compute all of
those partials all of those gradients
yeah so what's happening here is that
the way Pi torch works is that it's
storing the accumulate accumulated
gradient at X and so we've essentially
made two different
backwards passes we've called it once on
this function y and we've which is a
function of X and we've called it once
on Z which is also a function of X and
so you're right we can't actually
disambiguate which came from what we
just see the accumulated gradient but
typically that's actually exactly what
we want because what we want is to be
able to run our Network and accumulate
the gradient across all of the training
examples that Define our loss
and then perform our Optimizer step so
yeah even with respect to one thing it
doesn't matter because in practice each
of those things is really a different
example in our set of training examples
and so we're not interested in you know
the gradient from one example we're
actually interested in the overall
gradient
so going back to this example
What's Happening Here is that in the
backwards pass what it's doing is
you can imagine there's the X tensor and
then there's the dot grad attribute
which is another separate tensor it's
going to be the same shape as X
and what that is storing is it's storing
the accumulated gradient from every
single time that you've called dot
backward on a quantity that
essentially has some dependency on X
that will have a non-zero gradient and
so the first time we call it the
gradient will be 12 because 6X 6 times 2
12. the second time we do it with Z it's
also still 12. but the point is that dot
grad doesn't actually overwrite the
gradient each time you called out
backwards it simply adds them it
accumulates them and kind of the
intuition there is that
ultimately you're going to want to
compute the gradient with respect to the
loss and that loss is going to be made
up of many different examples and so you
need to accumulate the gradient from all
of those in order to make a single
update
and then of course you'll have to zero
that out because every time you make one
pass through all of your data you don't
want that next batch of data to also be
double counting the previous batches
update you want to keep those separate
and so we'll see that in a second
all right so now we're going to move on
to
one of the final pieces of the puzzle
which is neural networks how do we
actually use them in pi torch
and once we have that and we have our
optimization we'll finally be able to
figure out how do we actually train a
neural network what does that look like
and why it's so clean and efficient when
you do it in pi torch
so the first thing that you want to do
is
we're going to be defining neural
networks in terms of existing building
blocks in terms of existing apis which
will Implement for instance linear
layers or different activation functions
that we need so we're going to import
torch.nn
because that is the neural network
package that we're going to make use of
and so let's start with the linear layer
the way the linear layer Works in pi
torch is it takes in two arguments it
takes in the input Dimension and then
the output dimension
and so pretty much what it does is it
takes in some input
which has some arbitrary amount of
dimensions and then finally
the input Dimension and it will
essentially output it to that same set
of Dimensions except the output
dimension in the very last place
and you can think of the linear layer as
essentially just performing a simple ax
plus b by default it's going to
um it's going to apply a bias but you
can also disable that if you don't want
a bias term
and so let's look at a small example so
here we have our input
and
we're going to create a linear layer in
this case as an input size of four an
output size of two
and
all we're going to do is once we Define
it by instantiating it with nn.linear
whatever the name of our layer is in
this case we called it linear we just
essentially apply it with parentheses as
if it were a function to whatever input
and that actually does
the actual forward pass through this
linear layer to get our output
and so you can see that the original
shape was two by three by four then we
pass it through this linear layer which
has an output dimension of size two and
so ultimately our output is two by three
by two which is good that's what we
expect that's not shape error
but you know something common that
you'll see is you know maybe
uh you decide to
you get a little confused and maybe you
do let's say
two by two you match the wrong dimension
and so here we're going to get a shape
error
and you see that the error message isn't
as helpful because it's actually changed
the shape of what we were working with
we said this was two by three by four
under the hood Pi torch has changes to a
six by four but
if we you know in this case it's obvious
because we instantiated it with the
shape but if we didn't have the shape
then one simple thing we could do is
actually just print out the shape and
we'd see okay this last Dimension is
size four so I actually need to change
my input dimension in my linear layer to
be size four
thank you
and you'll also notice on this output we
have this grad function and so that's
because we're actually Computing and
storing the gradients here
for our tensor
yeah so typically we think of the First
Dimension as the batch Dimension so in
this case it said n this you can think
of as if you had a batch of images it
would be the number of images if you had
a training Corpus of text it would be
essentially the number of sentences or
sequences
um pretty much that is usually
considered the batch Dimension the star
indicates that there can be an arbitrary
number of dimensions
so for instance if we had images
this could be a four-dimensional tensor
object it could be the batch size by the
number of channels by the height by the
width
but in general there's no fixed number
of Dimensions your input tensor can be
any number of Dimensions the key is just
that that last Dimension needs to match
up with the input dimension of your
linear layer
the two is the output size so
essentially we're saying that we're
going to map
this last Dimension which is four
dimensional to now two dimensional
so in general you know you can think of
this is if we're stacking a neural
network this is kind of the input
Dimension size and this would be like
the hidden Dimension size
and so one thing we can do is we can
actually print out the parameters and we
can actually see what are the values of
our linear layer or in general for any
layer that we Define in our neural
network
what are the actual parameters and
in this case we see that there's two
sets of parameters
because we have a bias as well as the
actual
um
the actual linear layer itself
and so both of them store the gradients
and in this case
um you know these are these are what the
current values of these parameters are
and they'll change as we train the
network
okay so now let's go through some of the
other module layers
um
so in general nn.linear is one of the
layers you have access to you have a
couple of other different layers that
are pretty common you have 2D
convolutions you have transpose
convolutions you have batch Norm layers
when you need to do normalization in
your network
you can do up sampling you can do Max
pooling you can do lots of different
operators but the main key here is that
all of them are built-in building blocks
that you can just call just like we did
with nn.linear
and so
let's just go I guess I'm running out of
time but let's just try and go through
these last few layers and then I'll wrap
up by kind of showing an example that
puts it all together
so in this case we can define an
activation function which is typical
with our networks we need to introduce
non-linearities in this case we use the
sigmoid function and so now we can
Define our our Network as this very
simple thing which had one linear layer
and then an activation
and in general when we compose these
layers together we don't need to
actually write
every single line by line applying the
next layer we can actually stack all of
them together in this case we can use
nn.sequential and list all of the layers
so here we have our linear layer
followed by our sigmoid and then
now we're just essentially passing the
input through this whole set of layers
all at once so we take our input we call
block on the input and we get the output
and so
let's just kind of see putting it all
together what does it look like to
define a network and what does it look
like when we train one
so here we're going to actually Define a
multi-layer perceptron and the way it
works is to define a neural network you
extend the NN dot module class
the key here is there's really two main
things you have to Define when you
create your own network one is the
initialization so in the init function
you actually initialize all the
parameters you need in this case we
initialize an input size a hidden size
and we actually Define the model itself
in this case it's a simple model which
consists of a linear layer followed by
an activation followed by another linear
layer followed by a final activation
and the second function we have to
Define is the forward which actually
does the forward pass of the network and
so here our forward function takes in
our input X
in general it could take in some
arbitrary amount of inputs into this
function
but essentially it needs to figure out
how are you actually Computing the
output and in this case it's very simple
we just pass it into the network that we
just defined
and return the output
and
again you could do this more explicitly
by kind of doing what we did earlier
where we could actually write out all of
the layers individually instead of
wrapping them into one object
and then
doing a line by line operation for each
one of these layers
and so finally if we Define our class
it's very simple to use it we can now
just instantiate some input instantiate
our model by calling multi-layer
perceptron with our parameters and then
just pass it through our model
so that's great but this is all just a
full red pass how do we actually train
the network how do we actually make it
better
and so this is the final step which is
we have optimization built in to Pi
torch so we have this backward function
which goes and computes all these
gradients in the backward pass and now
the only step left is to actually update
the parameters using those gradients and
so here we'll import the torch.opt-in
package which contains all the
optimizers that you need
essentially this part is just creating
some random data so that we can actually
decide how to fit our data
but this is really the key here which is
we'll instantiate our model that we
defined
we'll Define the atom optimizer
um
and we'll Define it with a particular
learning rate we'll Define a loss
function which is again another built-in
module in this case we're using the
cross entropy loss
and finally to calculate our predictions
all we do is simply is just call model
on our actual input
and to calculate our loss we just call
our loss function on our predictions and
our true labels and we extract the
scalar here
and now when we put it all together this
is what the training Loop looks like
we have some number of epochs that we
want to train our Network
for each of these epochs the first thing
we do is we take our Optimizer and we
zero out the gradient and the reason we
do that is because like many of you
noted we actually are accumulating the
gradient we're not resetting it every
time we call Dot backward so we zero out
the gradient
we get our model predictions by doing a
forward pass
we then compute the loss between the
predictions and the True Values
finally we call law stop backward this
is what actually computes all the
gradients in the backward pass from our
loss
and the final step is we call Dot step
on our Optimizer in this case we're
using atom
and this will take a step on our loss
function and so if we run this code
we end up seeing that we're able to
start with some trading loss which is
relatively high and in 10 epochs we're
able to essentially completely fit our
data
and if we print out our model parameters
and we printed them out from the start
as well we'd see that they've changed as
we've actually done this optimization
so I'll kind of wrap it up here but I
think the key takeaway is that a lot of
the things that you're doing at the
beginning of this class are really about
understanding the basics of how neural
networks work how you actually Implement
them how you implement the backward pass
the great thing about Pi torch is that
once you get to the very next assignment
you'll see that now that you have a good
underlying understanding of those things
you can abstract a lot of the complexity
of how do you do back prop how do you
store all these gradients how do you
compute them how do you actually run the
optimizer and let pytorch handle all of
that for you and you can use all of
these building blocks all these
different neural network layers to now
Define your own networks that you can
use to solve whatever problems you need